- 양자 정보와 계산의 이해에
다시 오신 걸 환영해요.
저는 John Watrous이고
IBM Quantum Education의 기술 디렉터예요.
이번은 시리즈의 여섯 번째 강의이고, 양자 알고리즘에 관한
시리즈 두 번째 단원의 두 번째 강의예요.
지난 강의에서 우리는 계산의 질의
모델에 대해 이야기했고, 그 모델에서 양자 알고리즘이
놀라운 이점을 제공할 수 있다는 걸 봤어요.
고전 알고리즘에 비해서요. Simon 문제의 경우에는 지수적 이점까지 포함해서요.
안타깝게도 질의
모델은 직접적이거나 즉각적인
실용적 관련성이 별로 없어요.
블랙박스라는 개념은 알고 보면 매우 유용한
추상화인데, 우리가 적용하려면
좀 더 해야 할 일이 있어요.
질의 모델에서
얻은 통찰을 입력이 비트 문자열로 주어지는 좀 더 표준적인 계산 환경에 적용하려면요.
오라클이나 블랙박스가 아니라요.
이 강의의 주요 목적은 그것을 할 수 있는
기반을 마련하는 거예요.
강의 개요를 보면요. 강의의 대부분에서 우리는
계산 비용에 초점을 맞출 거예요.
다시 말해, 다양한
계산 작업이 얼마나 어렵고 그 어려움을 어떻게 측정할 수 있는지에 대해서요.
대략적으로 말하면, 이건 계산이 끝나길
얼마나 오래 기다려야 하는지, 궁극적으로 어떤
계산 문제를
풀 수 있고 어떤 것이
우리의 능력 밖인지로 이어져요.
몇 가지 예시부터
시작할 거예요. 정수 인수분해와 최대공약수,
줄여서 GCD 계산이에요.
이것들은 기본 원리를 설명하는 데 아주 좋은 예시이고,
둘 다 다음 강의에서 다룰 Shor 알고리즘과
매우 관련이 깊어요.
그래서 이 예시들로
두 배의 효과를 얻을 수 있을 거예요.
그런 다음 계산 비용의 개념을 좀 더 일반적으로 그리고 어떻게 측정할 수 있는지 이야기할 거예요.
이걸 할 수 있는 방법은
여러 가지가 있지만, circuit 모델의 계산에
꽤 좁게 초점을 맞출 거예요.
구체적으로 Boolean circuit과
quantum circuit이요.
여기서 초점은 예를 들어 컴퓨터
하드웨어가 아니라 알고리즘에 맞춰져 있고, 우리는 더 관심이 있어요.
알고리즘 실행 비용이 문제 인스턴스의 크기가 커질수록
어떻게 변하는지에 대해서요.
몇 초, 몇 분,
몇 시간이 걸리는지 같은
특정 계산 시간보다는요.
이런 관점을 이끄는 아이디어는 알고리즘이
근본적인 중요성을 가진다는 거예요.
오늘날까지도 우리는
아주 아주 오래전에 개발된 알고리즘을 여전히 실행하고 있고, 매우 자연스럽게 기술이 발전함에 따라
더 빠르고 더 안정적인 하드웨어를 사용해서
점점 더 큰 문제 인스턴스에 적용될 거예요.
그리고 그것들이 어떻게 확장되는지가 그것들이 얼마나 유용하고
앞으로도 얼마나 유용할지에 대해 많은 걸 알려줘요.
강의의 마지막 섹션에서는 매우 중요한 작업으로 넘어갈 건데, 바로 고전 계산을
양자 컴퓨터에서 실행하는 거예요. 이것이 중요한 이유는 고전 컴퓨터를
양자 컴퓨터로 대체하고 싶어서가 아니에요.
그건 곧 일어날 것 같지 않고 영원히 안 일어날 수도 있는데, 오히려 이것이 열어주는 건
양자 알고리즘을 위한
많은 흥미로운 가능성이에요.
구체적으로, 고전 계산을 양자 컴퓨터에서
실행하는 방법을 알게 되면, 양자 알고리즘의
서브루틴으로 사용할 수 있게 돼요.
그래서 양자 계산 이점을 추구하면서
고전 알고리즘에 대해 알고 있는 모든 것을 효과적으로 활용할 수 있어요.
오늘날 우리가 가진 고전 컴퓨터는 정말로 기술의 경이로운 산물이에요.
엄청나게 빠르지만, 어떤 계산 문제도
능력 밖이 아닐 만큼 빠르지는 않아요.
어떤 계산 문제들은 본질적으로 너무 어려워서
그것을 풀 알고리즘이 있긴 하지만, 오늘날 지구상의 어떤 컴퓨터도
사람의 수명 안에, 심지어
적당한 크기의 입력에 대해서도 이 알고리즘을 끝까지 실행할 만큼 빠르지 않아요.
심지어 지구 자체의
수명 안에서도요.
더 자세히 설명하기 위해,
정수 인수분해 문제를 살펴볼게요.
문제 설명은 아주 간단해요. 문제의 입력은 2 이상의 정수 N이고, 출력은
N의 소인수분해예요.
그게 의미하는 건 N의 소수 인수들의 목록과 함께 이 소수들을 곱해서
N을 얻기 위해 올려야 하는
거듭제곱이에요.
물론 소인수들을 어떤 순서로든 곱할 수 있지만, 순서를 제외하면
소인수분해는 모든 N의 선택에 대해 항상 유일해요.
그 사실은 산술의
기본 정리라고 불리고, 더 알고 싶으시면
많은 정수론 책의
맨 처음 부분에서
찾을 수 있어요.
아주 간단한 예로, 숫자 12의
소인수분해를 보여드릴게요.
2의 2제곱 곱하기
3의 1제곱이에요.